Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin der Osternat hier in der Notaufnahme.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz.
Danke schön.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen,
muss ich ganz schnell ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Sind Sie da mit einverstanden?
Ja, was Sie wissen müssen, wissen Sie.
Das ist ja kein Ding.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Maria Zimmermann.
Double M und Double N.
Ja, okay.
In der Mitte Double M und am Ende Double N.
Double N, ja, okay.
Frau Zimmermann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin jetzt in ein paar Tagen, werde ich 66.
Wie wurden Sie genau geboren?
Am 2. Mai 57.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1,70 Meter, wahrscheinlich immer noch ungefähr.
Und ich wiege 78 kg.
78 kg.
Okay, sehr gut.
Danke schön für die Information.
Und was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, also ich habe solche Bauschmerzen.
Überwiegend eigentlich auf der linken Seite im Unterbau.
Und das hat vor einigen Wochen angefangen.
Dann war es auch wieder weg.
Ich habe das gemerkt, dass ich so fettiges Essen nicht gut vertragen habe.
Da habe ich dann so Brinnen bekommen.
Und ja, also in der letzten Zeit habe ich immer so ein bisschen Bauchprobleme gehabt.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, war ich total verstopft.
Und dann hatte ich wieder Durchfall.
Und dann war es wieder ganz schwierig.
Mit dem Bauch ist irgendwas nicht in Ordnung.
Und jetzt werden die Schmerzen auch irgendwie schlimmer.
Die waren am Anfang gar nicht so doll.
Und die werden aber jetzt immer heftiger.
Und das habe ich gedacht, ich muss doch mal zu Ihnen kommen.
Ja, und Sie haben vor einigen Wochen angefangen gesagt.
Ja, da habe ich das schon mal gehabt.
Und dann ist es aber wieder weggegangen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen genau?
Ja, also so wie Sie jetzt sind, habe ich sie vielleicht seit zwei Wochen.
Aber vor vier Wochen war schon einmal so eine Phase.
Da war es aber dann ganz schnell wieder vorbei.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt auf der linken Seite.
Auf der linken Seite, genau.
Ja, auf der linken Seite.
Zeigen Sie mir bitte, wo die Schmerzen am stärksten sind.
Die sitzen eigentlich ziemlich genau im Unterbau.
Also wenn ich praktisch die Hand unterhalb vom Bauch labellege.
Ja, okay.
Unterhalb, dann auf der linken Seite.
Unterhalb der Bauch.
Ja, okay.
Und sind die Strahlen die Schmerzen in einer anderen Körperregion aus?
Hab ich nicht den Eindruck, nein, ich meine, die sind da an der Stelle und da bleiben die auch.
Ja, und sind die Schmerzen auch wieder weg?
Ja, also sie waren seit vier Wochen weg.
Ja.
Aber jetzt sind sie eigentlich die ganze Zeit da und werden eigentlich auch heftiger.
Ja, auf einer Schmerzskalifon ein bis zehn, wobei ein sehr leichten und zehn außerordentlicher Tag.
Schmerzen entschüpflicht.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Ja, also ich würde vielleicht sagen, so direkt nach dem Essen manchmal,
da sind die schon so bei sieben und normalerweise sind ja erträglich, aber vielleicht so bei vier, fünf.
Ja, fünf, okay.
Und gibt es für die Schmerzen bestimmte Auslöser oder bestimmte Lebensmittel?
Zum Beispiel fettiges Essen oder wirziges Essen?
Ja, also den Eindruck habe ich, dass fettiges Essen nicht gut ist.
Und da habe ich jetzt auch die Tage dann darauf verzichtet.
Ja, okay.
Gibt es etwas, was ich meine, Kinder oder für Stärk?
Also, was mir aufgefallen ist, wenn ich mich hinter und ruhig bin, dann wird es ein bisschen besser.
Aber wenn ich unterwegs bin, dann ist es nicht gut.
Ja, okay, ganz gut.
Haben die Schmerzen sich im Laufe der Zeit verbessert oder schlechter?
Immer schlechter, ne?
Sie sind eigentlich immer schlechter geworden, würde ich sagen.
Wenn Sie unterhalb auf der linken Seite aufdrücken und die loslässt,
sind die Schmerzen verstärkt?
Sie stellen schwierige Fragen.
Ich würde sagen, sie bleiben gleich.
Ja, klar, bleiben.
Okay, bleiben.
Und wenn die Attacke kommt,
wie lange dauert die Schmerzen?
Das dauert schon relativ lange, würde ich sagen.
Also, das kommt mir immer lange vor.
Vielleicht so eine halbe Stunde nach dem Essen oder vielleicht auch eine Stunde.
Und dann flaut es wieder so ein bisschen ab.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, manchmal Verstopfung und manchmal Durchfall?
Ja, das habe ich aber schon lange.
Schon lange, aber nicht jetzt.
Ne, das habe ich schon eigentlich seit, ja, ich würde sagen, bestimmt zwei Jahren.
Ja, haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, erbrochen muss nicht übernehmen, das muss ich nicht.
Haben Sie nauseher?
Was meinen Sie mit nauseher?
Ist Ihnen öbel?
Ne, so richtig schlecht ist mir nicht.
Haben Sie keine Öbelkeit?
Ne, würde ich nicht sagen.
Also nur wenn die Schmerzen ganz heftig sind,
dann fühlt man sich halt insgesamt schlecht, ja.
Okay, wie war der Stuhl von der Farbe?
Also ich würde sagen normal.
Also ein bisschen natürlich orientiert an dem, was man gegessen hat.
Also, was ich, so was wie Spinat oder Rote Beete, verabt natürlich.
Aber sonst würde ich sagen, hat das eine normale Farbe gehabt, der Stuhlgang?
Und mir ist auch nicht aufgefallen, dass der sich irgendwie besonders verändert hat.
Haben Sie denn T-Stuhl nicht bemerkt, ne? T-Stuhl.
Was ist T-Stuhl?
T-Stuhl bedeutet glänzende schwarze Stuhl.
Ne, Schwarz war der nicht, ne?
Ganz geltlich, nicht Schwarz, ja.
Also eher so bräunlicher, wie halt das Stuhl aussieht, ja.
Ja, okay, bräulich, okay.
Und haben Sie Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Also, was war die Mama?
Mir war jetzt die letzten Tage ein bisschen warm, und da habe ich mal gemessen.
Da war die Temperatur ein bisschen erhöht, also knapp unter 38.
38, aber unter?
Ja, runter, kurz drunter.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie nicht Nachschweiß bemerkt?
Die Schütze habe ich nachts nicht besonders, nein.
Ja, okay.
Ist Ihnen, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht, nein.
Ja, okay.
Können Sie hinter dem Brustbein, Brustengefühl oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Nein, Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht, Brustschmerzen.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Husten?
Husten?
Nein, so teilt nicht.
Ganz gut, Husten.
Okay, Frau Zimmermann, haben Sie in der letzten sechs Monate ab oder zu genommen?
Ich glaube nicht, nein, das wüsste ich, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Geh mich da los, dann rein.
Und haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, mit dem durchschlafen, das ist nicht so toll.
Also ich wach wohl manchmal auf, ich glaube auch mit Bauchschmerzen.
Und dann muss ich auch immer nachts auf die Toilette geben.
Bestimmt so, ja, wenigstens einmal in der Nacht, manchmal auch zweimal.
Gut, wie ist die Appetit?
Ja, der war schon mal besser.
Also in letzter Zeit, Speck, das ist mir nicht so sehr gut.
Nicht sehr gut.
Okay, und leiden einen Moment, bekommen Sie immer noch Naturation, oder?
Nein, ich bin 66, Gottes Willen, nein, die Zeit ist lange vorbei.
Ja, okay.
Ganz gut, haben Sie Allergien, Frau Zimmermann?
Ja, was ich nicht so gut vertragen habe, sind Milchprodukte, da verzichte ich auch weitgehend drauf.
Ja gut, wie äußert sich diese Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, wenn ich viel Milchprodukte esse, dann hatte ich auch Darmbeschwerden, deswegen habe ich das dann reduziert.
Ja, die Umgebung auch.
Und ich würde nun nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen, aber davor müssen Sie etwas hinzufügen, Frau Zimmermann.
Ja, ich habe immer viel gefragt, ich habe glaube ich alles erzählt, was jetzt so wichtig war für diese Tage.
Ja, okay, gab es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe das, was alle Leute in meinem Alter haben, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, ich habe ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfettwerte.
Vor 20 Jahren ist bei mir die Geilenblase rausgenommen worden.
Ganz schön, und ist die Operation komplikationlos verläuft?
Ja, das war so ein kleiner Eingriff, da war nicht viel.
Ja, sehr gut, und gab es in der Vorgeschichte wichtige Operationen, außer...
Nein, das war die einzige, das war das einzige.
Sehr gut, und ich würde Sie nach Ihrer Lebensgewohnheiten fragen, und rauchen Sie, Frau Zimmermann.
Nein, ich habe tatsächlich noch nie geraucht.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also beleg nicht, trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, im Sommer mein Glas Rotwein, oder Glas Weißwein auf der Terrasse, oder wenn man Gäste hat, oder ein Glas Sekt,
im Winter mein Rotwein, oder zum Guten Essen mal ein Glas Wein, aber jetzt nicht jeden Abend.
Wie oft, können wir sagen, pro Woche ein paar Einglas waren?
Ja, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr, vielleicht zweimal in der Woche.
Sehr gut, zweimal, so hoch.
Und nehmen Sie bitte das nicht persönlich, aber das ist eine Routinefrage, die jede Patientin stellen muss.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen, Frau Zimmermann.
Drogen? Ich? Nein, also wirklich nicht, nein.
Sehr gut, sehr gut zu hören.
Und ja, ich würde Ihnen über Ihre Familie vorgeschickt sprechen.
Und leiden Ihr Vater oder Ihr Angehörigen unter wichtige Erkrankungen.
Na ja, also mein Vater, der ist verstorben, der hatte ja Lungenkrebs und hat dann letztendlich aber, was ihn gestorben,
an einem Schlaganfall.
Wann war das?
Oh, wie alt war der da, da war der 82 oder so.
Also ist schon noch relativ alt geworden.
Ja, okay.
Und bei der Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat Diabetes, also so ein altes Diabetes halt.
Ja, nur das.
Und wie viel ich weiß, ja, was die sonst noch hat, keine Ahnung.
Ganz schön, ganz schön.
Und haben Sie Geschwister Frau Zimmermann?
Nein, Geschwister gibt es nicht.
Sind Sie Einzelkind? Sehr gut.
Ich bin ein Einzelkind, ja.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ja, ich bin Rentner natürlich inzwischen.
Aber vorher?
Ja, ich habe als Beraterin in einem Möbelhaus gearbeitet.
Ein Möbelhaus, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder, die sind aber natürlich schon erwachsen.
Sehr gut.
Und sind Kinder gesund?
Kinder sind gesund, ja, so viele falls, ja.
Ja, gut.
Und wollen Sie allein oder mit meinem Mann zusammenwohnen?
Mein Mann, ja, sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Ja, das war Frau Zimmermann.
Ja, ich,
ich habe alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt
und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder hätten Sie?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich noch sagen soll.
Sie haben ja so viel gefragt und ich habe Ihnen ja so viel erzählt.
Ich wüsste nicht, was da noch fehlen könnte, ja.
Und ich wüsste jetzt natürlich vorherkommen diese Bauchschmerzen
und was machen Sie, um das rauszufinden?
Ich möchte etwas zuerst Köpferchen untersuchen
und danach ich brauche Labo-Untersuchungen,
um etwas herauszufinden.
Und natürlich, ich brauche Labo-Jagnostik
und gegebenenfalls würde ich
Kontrast, City-Tomographie, der Bauch,
veranlassen.
Das Bauch ist.
Das Bauch ist veranlassen.
Ja, ja, was ist denn eine City-Tomographie?
Können Sie mir das erklären?
Ja, City-Tomographie ist ein Bild gegebener Untersuchung.
Eine bildgebende Untersuchung, ja?
Ja, eine bildgebende Untersuchung.
Und wir können als Ärzte in Schnittbildern
ihre Bauch- und Bauchorgane sehen.
Aber ist das denn mit Strahlenbelastung?
Ja, es hat Strahlen.
Also es gibt alle Strahlenbelastung, aber ist das gefährlich?
Nein, das ist nicht gefährlich.
Wir machen jeden Tag City-Tomographie
und das ist nicht ganz gefährlich.
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen gefährlich,
ja, er hat ein bisschen gefährlich, aber...
Was ist denn die Gefahr?
Ist das mit dem Kontrastmittel?
Oder was ist gefährlich?
Kontrastmittel haben Sie dagegen,
Kontrastmittel-Allergie haben...
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe noch nie Kontrastmittel bekommen.
Aber wir würden natürlich Therapie verbreiten.
Was etwas Schlechtes passiert, dann...
Dann retten Sie mich.
Ja.
Das ist schon mal gut, ja.
Okay, will ich mich damit verlassen?
Ja.
Gut, sonst habe ich eigentlich...
Aber muss diese Untersuchung unbedingt sein?
Es muss nicht sein,
nach der Ergebnisse von Blutabnehmen
oder Blut,
wie wir das Blutdiagnostik möchten.
Wenn es erforderlich ist,
würden wir diese Untersuchung entfernen lassen.
Ah, ja, okay, gut.
Gut, aber gibt es nicht noch einfache Untersuchungen,
die nicht so gefährlich sind?
Ja, natürlich gibt es ein Bauchutraschall.
Ah, das habe ich schon mal gehört, das ist nicht gefährlich, ne?
Ja, das ist nicht gefährlich.
Und es ist Bauchutraschall, ist strahlenfreie.
Mhm.
Wir können das ja erst machen.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Alles klar.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie mir etwas über Ihren psychischen Zustand beschreiben?
Ein psychischen Zustand?
Ja, gibt es Faktoren zum Beispiel...
Ich bin Render, ich habe keinen Stress.
Und in der Familie gibt es auch keinen Ärger.
Danke schön.
Hat noch sonst jemand eine Frage?
Mir ist auch, dass er zum Impfel hat nichts gefragt.
Ja, Impfel.
Corona schon vergessen?
Hallo, Herr Uster, sind Sie noch da?
Ja, ich bin hier.
Und Medikamente haben Sie auch nicht gefragt?
Oh, Sie haben vergessen.
Oh, Entschuldigung.
Ja, nehmen Sie es.
Sie sind der Arzt, nicht ich?
Ja, nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein.
Ja, ich nehme regelmäßig Medikamente ein.
Ich nehme einen Betaflocher wegen meines Blutdrucks.
Ja, Betaflocher.
Und wenn ich nachts nicht gut schlafen kann,
nehme ich Baldrian.
Und wegen der erhöhten Cholesterinwerte
nehme ich Atrovastatin.
Kennen Sie da Dosierung?
Ja, dann nehme ich 20 Milligramm eine Abend.
Ja, eine Abend.
Und Betaflocher, wissen Sie,
die Namen des Medikaments?
Oh, die Namen weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass das vom Betaflocher ist
und abends eine nehme.
Ja, zweimal.
Und Baldrian?
Bitte?
Wofür nehmen Sie Baldrian?
Wenn ich nachts nicht schlafen kann.
Okay.
Hatten Sie schon einmal Magen oder Spiegelung?
Oh, das ist aber sehr lange her.
Das ist mehr als zehn Jahre her.
Da hatte ich eine Darmspiegelung.
Okay.
Was alles in Ordnung?
Damals war alles in Ordnung, ja.
Haben Sie wegen Verstopfung und Durchfall beurteilt?
Nein, da bin ich noch nicht beim Arzt gewesen.
Okay.
Danke.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, hat er gefragt. Ich bin Einzelkind.
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Danke.
Vielen Dank, haben wir schon gefragt.
Hat er gefragt, ja.
Können wir erst als Geschäpfung anfangen?
Ja, können wir anfangen.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag, liebe Kolleginnen.
Hallo, ja, unsere Oberärztin.
Ich würde Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen,
die ich gerade in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Darf ich?
Natürlich, erzählen Sie.
Wen haben Sie gesehen?
Ja, Frau Maria Simmermann ist 60-Jährige Frau.
Sie ist 2.5.1957 geboren und 1,78 m groß und 68 kg schwer.
78?
78, ja, 78 kg schwer.
Und Frau Simmermann hat sich bei uns seit 4 Wochen bestehende.
Einmal fertigreden, erst mal den Platz fertig machen.
Ja, seit einer Woche bestehende, progriertierte Bauchschmerzen
auf der linken Seite im Unterbauch vorgestellt.
Und die Auslöser für die Schmerzen ist fettiges Essen.
Die Schmerzen haben sich immer verschlechtert.
Und die Ferner klackten sie über und so drinnen.
Und Appetitlosigkeit und Schlaflosigkeit.
Und die Intensität der Schmerzen liegt nach dem Essen bei 7.
Und die Intensität der Schmerzen liegt in Ruhe bei 4 bis 5.
Und die Patienten füllen hat Fieber seit 3 Tagen.
Und die Patienten hat Zub-Februar.
Die Frage nach Gewichtverlust und Schüttefrust wurde verneint.
Und die Unverträglichkeiten der Patienten sind Milchprodukte.
Die Patienten beschreibt eine Unverträglichkeit auf Milchprodukte.
Und sie beidet sie aber.
Sie verzichtet auf Milchprodukte.
Sie trinkt Alkohol 2-mal pro Woche.
Die Frage nach Drogenkonsum wurde von der Patientin verneint.
Und bei der Familie Anemnäse befinden sich bei Vater Lungenkrebs.
Und die Frage nach der Familie Anemnäse befinden sich bei Vater Lungenkrebs.
Und bei der Familie Anemnäse befinden sich bei Mutter Milchprodukte.
Und sie ist ein Kind und sozial an einem Nestig.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat 2 Kinder.
Und sie wohnt mit ihrem Ehemann.
Und die Kinder sind aber erwachsen.
Ja, sie hat 2 Kinder und sie sind gesund.
Also 2 erwachsene Kinder, die gesund sind.
Die Schmerzen sind ohne Ausstrahlung.
Nur unter Bauch.
Nach der Aufgrund der Symptomatik gehe ich von einem Darmkrebs aus.
Oder meine erste phrenzialen Diagnose kommen in Betracht.
Die Diagnose sind Darmkrebs und Diwertikulitis.
Da mag ich Zyndrom und Reizdarm.
Reizdarm-Zyndrom? Ja.
Reizdarm-Zyndrom.
Und vielleicht Morbuschkrom.
Ich habe hier auch als Differentialdiagnose.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Ich würde Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Was achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich würde darauf achten, dass Sie die Empfindlichkeit oder die Loslassschmerzen und Abdeh-Spannung im Bauch hatten.
Und vielleicht bei der Auskultation kann ich Darm-Geräusche erhöht werden.
Oder Sie haben Verstärkungen und Durchfall.
Worauf schauen Sie noch im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Was bietet sich da noch so an?
Vielleicht Gert Siklerikterus.
Ich meine, es gibt noch etwas anderes.
Sie haben ja auch einen Karzinom.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Ich taste die Lämpfknotenstation ab.
Ich habe hier ein kleines Blutbild und Blutzucker und Entzündungsparameter.
Wir sind auf den Darm-Fokus.
Und Stuhldiagnosik?
Ja, das bietet sich auch noch an.
Was machen Sie technisch?
Technisch.
Zuerst würde ich ein Sonographie des Bauches durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Ich würde ein Mass im Bauch sehen.
Und vielleicht der fettige Leber sehen.
Ich kann nicht die Kalen belasten sehen.
Sie wurden qualifiziert.
Was wäre noch als zusätzliche Diagnostik möglich?
Ich würde Kolonspiegel empfehlen.
Ich kann eine Gewerfrobe entnehmen.
Und nach Pathologie schicken.
Und dann ein technisches Verfahren.
Ich würde eine Tomografie des Bauches mit Kontrastmittel veranlassen.
Was wären die Behandlungsoptionen?
Ich würde eine Schirurgische Konzil empfehlen.
Ich würde eine Diagnose bestätigen.
Was würden Sie bei der Diwetikulitis machen?
Ich würde eine Diwetikulitis empfehlen.
Es gibt eine Zange am Ende des Kolonskopie.
Was ist die Voraussetzung für die gute Frau?
Sie müssen vor Zwischstunden nüchtern sein.
Was machen wir noch?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ausgeprägt die Diwetikulose sein kann.
Die Diwetikulitis.
Das war die richtige Diagnose.
Ich würde eine Diagnose beenden.
Sie haben Probleme mit der Sprache.
Das ist ein normaler Satzbau.
Die Frage nach Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Ich würde Ihnen über Vorgeschichte sprechen.
Das sind kleine grammatikalische Verhalten.
Ich brauche eine Laborwerte.
Wenn Sie etwas wegsetzen, dann dreht sich das Umdrehen.
Was habe ich noch gefunden?
Ich habe noch nicht nach Medikamenten gefragt.
Sie machen sehr viele Stöckungen.
Versuche Sie das zu glätten.
Das ist schwierig innerhalb kurzer Zeit.
Das ist ein deutscher Sprachler.
Es waren viele Pausen.
Ich habe nicht die Prüfer abgefahren.
Versuche Sie es noch ein bisschen zu arbeiten.
Ich habe noch nicht das Problem.
Bei den Fragen haben Sie mehr Standardformulierungen.
Ich kann Ihnen anbieten, dass Sie Ihren Bericht schriftlich niederlegen.
Sie korrigieren ihn nicht.
Schreiben Sie ihn auf.
Das wäre ein Angebot.
Versuchen Sie sich, sich am regulären Satzbau zu orientieren.
Das ist relativ wichtig.
Sie haben etwas im Bericht.
Sie haben die Schmerzen nicht ausstrahlen.
Sie haben die Schmerzen vor vier Wochen schon mal ähnliche Beschwerden.
Sie haben auch nicht dazu gedacht, dass Sie schon die Verdauungsprobleme haben.
Sie haben nicht gesagt, dass Sie das schon jahrelang haben.
Das war ziemlich gut.
Das war ein bisschen Arbeit.